golf c'est tout c'est un dossier c'est
une chose l'occupation illégale qui ce
fait du chemin du maine c'est une autre
affaire je ne peux pas accepter que
lorsque les forces policières font
appliquer la loi y ait des victimes
qu'on demande en eau connu ce matin
elle aux policiers il n'est pas question
que l'on négocié alors que les
barricades sont maintenues alors que les
armes sont utilisées pour provoquer je
sais que vous tenez j'ai inséré des
champions dames indignes et le premier
ministre du québec a demandé l'aide des
forces canadiennes pour aider les
parties à mettre fin à la confrontation
[Applaudissements]
elles sont pas là bas la facétie de
banque qu'il fonda
je n'avais plus d'un mois soit pas
d'armé ne donne elle met la main au wac
à des bandits comme une aile n'avons
plus arriver à une entente pour la
liberté heures du conte
douch le deuil n'est pas mal mais on
s'est empalé barricades
on a dégagé les romains ont concédé une
opposition à l'ouest du docob honor
différents boss est et quel projet pour
pointer peur chaud chaud
[Applaudissements]
bah
[Musique]
cette solution pacifique nous permet de
garder cette réconciliation possible
avec les couilles souhaitable avec les
groupes autochtones
[Musique]